.
Let's say I have a triangle.
Here is my triangle.
And I know only the lengths of the sides of the triangle.
This side has length "a", this side has length "b", and
this country has a length of "c".
And I'm told to find the face of this triangle.
So far, everything I have is the idea that the person,
the face of a triangle is equal to 1/2 on the base of the triangle
triangle, at the height of the triangle.
The way I have drawn this triangle, the basis of this
triangle, will be a "c" side, but we do not know the height.
The height will be that "h" right there and we
we do not even know how much this "h" is.
So, it will be "h".
The question is how to diminish the face
of this triangle?
If you have watched the last video, you know that
use the formula of Heron.
But the idea here is to try to prove the Heron formula.
So, let's just try to find "h" just using the
Pythagorean theorem.
And from there, once we know h, we can apply this formula
to find the face of this triangle.
We have already noted this as "h".
Let's define another variable here.
Let me determine ...
This is a trick that you will see quite often in geometry.
Let us define this as "x" and if it is "x" in purple, then in
this blue-violet color, it will be "c" minus "x", right?
This whole length is "c" - the whole base is "c".
So if this part is "x", then this part is "c" minus "x".
What I can do now, as these both are right angles
and I know this because this is the height, I can do two
equations with the Pythagorean theorem.
First, I can do this on the left side and I can write that
"x" of square plus "h" of square is equal to "a" square.
That's what I get from this triangle on the left.
Then from this triangle on the right side, I get "c" minus "x"
the square plus "h" of the square is equal to the "b" square.
I assume I know "a", "b" and "c", so I have two equations
with two unknowns.
The unknowns are "x" and "h".
And do not forget that "h" is what we are trying to find,
because we already know "c".
If we know h, we can apply the formula to the person.
How can we do that?
Okay, let's replace "h" to find "x".
When I say this, I mean to find "h" in a square here.
If we find "h" in a square here, just subtract "x"
squares on both sides.
We can write that "x" of a square - sorry, we can write that
"h" per square is equal to "a" square minus "x" square.
Then we can take that information and replace it
here "h" per square.
So, this inferior equation turns into "c" minus "x"
a square plus "h" per square.
We know "h" on a square of this arrangement on the left.
"h" of square will be equal to - and so plus, I'll do it
in this color - "a" of square minus "x" per square is equal to "b" per square.
I just replaced the value of this here,
the value of that there.
Now let's expand this expression.
"with" minus "x" per square, this is "c" per square minus
"2cx" plus "x" per square.
Then we have a minus - excuse, we have plus "a"
square, minus "x" square is equal to "b" square,
is equal to the "b" square.
We have "x" of the square and "a" minus "x" of a square there,
so these are canceled.
These are canceled
Let's add "2cx" to both sides of this equation.
Now our equation will become a "c" square
plus "a" square.
I add "2cx" to both sides.
Add "2cx" to this, you get 0 is equal to
"b" square plus "2cx".
All I did here is that I canceled "x" on a square and then
I added "2cx" to both sides of this equation.
My goal here is to find "x".
Once I find "x", I can find "h"
to apply this formula.
Now, to find "x", let's take a "b" into a square
from both sides.
We get the "c" square plus "a" square, minus "b"
the square is equal to "2cx".
Then, if we divide both sides to "2c", we get a "c" square plus "a"
square minus "b" square on "2c" is equal to "x".
We just found "x" here.
Now, our goal is to find the height, so yes
we can apply 1/2 at the base, height.
To do this, you return to this equation here
and we find our height.
Let me roll a little down.
We know that our square height is equal to "a"
square minus "x" square.
Instead of writing an "x" square, let's replace it here.
This is a minus "x" per square - x is this thing here.
So, "with" the square plus "a" of the square, minus "b" of the square
on "2c" per square.
This is the same thing as the square x.
We have just found this.
So, "h" will be equal to the square root of all this
work there - will change the colors - to "a"
square minus "c" square, plus "a" square, minus "b" square
- all in a square.
Let me do it a little nicer than that because
I do not want to -...
Square root - make sure that I have enough space - from "a"
square minus all of these things on a square - we have a "c" square
plus "a" square, minus "b" square, all on "2c".
This is the height of our triangle.
The triangle we started up here.
Let me copy this, just to remember,
with what we have to do.
Copy it and then put it down here.
I put it down here.
We know how tall it is - it's great
complex formula.
The height, in terms of "a", "b" and "c" is right here.
So if we want to find the face - our face
triangle - let's do it in pink.
The face of our triangle will be 1/2 on our foundation
- our base is the whole length "c" - "c", ours
height, which is the expression here.
Let's just copy it instead of ....
Let me copy it.
And so on the height.
So, this is now our expression for the person.
Now you will say - Watch it, it does not look very much
of the Heron formula and you are right.
This is not much like the Heron formula, but what it is
I'll show you in the next video is that this essentially
is the Heron formula.
This is a harder-to-remember version of Heron's formula.
I'll put a lot of the algebra to make it simple
this to the Heron formula.
But that will do the job.
If you could remember that, I think Heron's a lot
easier to remember.
But if you can remember this and you know "a", "b" and
"c", apply this formula here and you will get it
the face of a triangle.
Actually, let me put this down just to show that
at least gives the same numbers as the Heroes.
In the last video we had a triangle that had sides 9, 11
and 16, and his face, using the Genoa formula, was equal to 18
square root of 7.
Let's see what we get when we apply this formula here.
We get that person equal to 1/2 at 16, by
square root of "a" per square.
This is 81 minus - let's see, "c" of a square is 16, so that's 256.
256 plus "a" square, which is 81, minus "b" square,
so minus 121.
All this is a square.
All this on 2 by "c" - all on 32.
Let's see if we can simplify this a bit.
81 minus 121, it's minus 40.
So, this becomes 216 on 32.
The area is equal to 1/2 by 8 is 8.
Let me change the colors.
1/2 by 16 is 8, by square root of 81 minus 256.
81 minus 121, it's minus 40.
256 minus 40 is 216.
216 on 32 per square.
Now, it's a lot of math, so let's do it
takes a calculator.
I'm just really trying to show you these two numbers
must give us the same as our number.
If we run our calculator ...
First, let's find out how old it is
square root of 7.
18 by square root of 7 - that's what
we get using the Heron formula.
Obtained 47.62.
Let's see if this is 47.62.
We have 8 by square root of 81 minus 216 divided
32 square meters and then close our square root.
And we get exactly the same number.
I was worried - I did not actually calculate that
in advance, so I may have made a mistake of inattention.
But here you are getting exactly the same number.
So, our formula now gave us exactly the same value
as the Heron formula.
But what I will do in the next video is to prove you that
this can actually be reduced algebraically to the Heron formula.
.